in 1910 a few years after the first
flight the Wright brothers started to
sell aircraft the model B wasn't some
experimental prototype or a custom build
these were made to order about a hundred
of them for civilians and the US
military only two of those aircraft
survive one of them is on display near
here at the U.S Air Force Museum in
Dayton Ohio and the other one
[Music]
on the ground
we went with a look-alike because there
are actual replicas people have built
very close to scale replicas of a 1911
1910 Wright flyer but they found the
same problems the rights did the
airplane isn't exactly what you call
Reliable very often it crashed and
frankly we don't want to have to fix our
airplane after every flight we don't
like the crash word so we built out of
modern materials with modern building
techniques so that we could fly on a
frequent basis we'd like to be able to
land the airplane and put somebody else
on it and continue flying
this is amazing
I can see why you're wearing
the airplane is very very close to what
a 1911 rate B flyer would have looked
like once you get 100 200 feet away from
it if we overfly people a 1911 right
Flyers which you see we're trying to
recreate in what people in 1911 Dayton
Ohio would have seen if Orville or
Wilbur had flown over top of them and
when you're inside the airplane this is
not an open cockpit airplane this is a
no cockpit airplane you were literally
sitting in front of the wing and
experiencing Flight of the way that
people did at the early turn of the
century
sorry aluminum construction
just like they were in the original of
These Wings Are covered in fabric like
the original although these days it's a
lot of material of science traffic there
are a few other changes too like how you
steer the rights knew that in order to
roll the airplane they had to change the
lift of each Wing they literally just
Twisted the wings the wood would bend
inside the airplane they had the small
tray that they sat on and when they
shifted their body there was wires that
were hooked to the ends of the wing and
that would twist each Wing in in
opposite directions to be able to give
them that lift differential the replicas
that have flown have done that it's
incredibly difficult to be able to
control so to be able to get something
where you can safely and repeatedly do
that is very very very challenging and
that's why we went with the ailerons
modified the exact same place
the rights actually started out as
bicycle Engineers if you will they were
bicycle mechanics so they were very
familiar with chains and when they
realized they could only have one engine
but they needed two propellers to
generate the thrust that they needed to
overcome the weight they very quickly
realized a single chain going to each
propeller one of them is inverted so
that you have Conor retaining propellers
was the way to do it so we've done the
same thing on our airplane we have one
engine and we have two propellers that
are driven by frankly a very very very
strong and very industrial chain yes it
looks like a bicycle chain but when you
get up close to it we've got a pretty
pretty solid chain on this airplane for
very good reasons we have a Lycoming
io390 probably the largest four-cylinder
general aviation engine that we could
get to put on the airplane so rated at
210 horsepower the rights had anywhere
from 32 to around 40 horsepower but
sometimes you got a little less
sometimes you got a little more because
they were all hand built
who is foreign
[Music]
it actually flies much like any other
conventional general aviation airplane
except for the fact that you're not
sitting inside of the airplane when you
fly you and I are both part of the drag
equation of this airplane you are
impacting the drag of the airplane when
you stick your hand out and wave she's
got a personality to her and that's why
we're required to go through the flight
test process because the FAA knows the
airplane is going to have a personality
the FAA has a very rigorous process when
you're building even an experimental
airplane we loaded the wings down with
salt bags to simulate the load of three
and a half G's so the airplane we know
can pull three and a half G's you're
never going to see three and a half G's
in this airplane we've been up to maybe
1.2 G's in a 30 degree Bank turn and
that's about as steep as we're going to
go because we don't need to do anything
more than that so maybe we over
engineered the airplane but you know to
me when I'm flying it that's the kind of
stuff I'm really interested in having
underneath me I'd like to think that
somewhere down there as we come into
last there's a kid just looking out the
window and going
we get a lot of head turning we get a
lot of waves as we go by we're trying to
preserve early aviation history I've
been airborne and I've looked down and
there's another airplane flying
underneath of me and that's just a view
that you don't get from many other
airplanes
and it is the greatest knife drop that
I've ever heard in my life our original
airplane we call the brown bird it first
flew in 1982 it has flown over 5 100
passengers over the years really fun to
fly but we're going something now that's
a little bit more advanced a little bit
easier to move around
[Music]
a lot of people that have come out over
the years have said hey I'm a pilot I've
got years of experience I would really
like to fly your airplane and we don't
let other people fly the airplane and
it's very difficult to fly the airplane
we did make an exception once about 15
years ago we took a look at his
credentials and we thought okay you know
what we're going to give this this
gentleman a chance and it was impressive
how well he could control the airplane
his name happened to be Neil Armstrong
so we've told other people if you've
walked on the moon we'll probably let
you come fly our airplane but until then
you know we're we're just going to kind
of take you for a ride when we take you
flying thank you all right thank you so
so much that was
incredible